let's talk about obstruction of justice
there has been a growing focus when we
talk about Donald Trump and the Trump
Russia investigation on whether or not
Donald Trump may have obstructed justice
we learned that Donald Trump knew back
in January of 2017 that Michael Flynn
had misled the FBI and lied to Mike
Pence and then he tried to get the
investigation shut down by James Comey
he wanted James Comey to end the
investigation we have learned that
Donald Trump contacted multiple
Republican senators over the summer to
get the investigation shut down and as
much as the Russia collusion itself is a
matter of discussion obstruction of
justice which we could call generally
kind of part of the cover-up is also a
big matter and John Dowd is one of
Donald Trump's lawyers and he had a
sword of Richard Nixon moment where he
told Mike Allen of Axios that the
president simply cannot be guilty of
obstruction of justice John Dowd saying
quote the president cannot obstruct
justice because he is the chief law
enforcement officer under the
Constitution's article 2 and has every
right to express his view of any case
when I read this I thought this is the
2017 version of this now infamous quote
from President Richard Nixon it is not
illegal this is and if the President
does it it's not a legal argument
plain and simple now Trump's attorney
John Dowd is saying while we believe
that the president cannot obstruct
justice
that is not our defense we still of
course don't believe that he did but by
the way don't waste your time because we
believe that the president cannot
obstruct justice this is another way of
saying I'm above the law I'm above the
law period and there are two questions
here
number one is John Dowd correct and
number two why does this matter let's
take the second part first why is this
huge this is huge because the goalposts
keep moving right first it was there was
no investing there will be no
investigation then it's okay fine an
investigation has started
but it's going to find nothing and then
it's okay the investigation did lead to
some indictments but they're not related
to anything Trump did or knew about the
goal posts keep moving here's another
example
at first it was of course there's no
collusion and then it became collusion
wouldn't necessarily be illegal and with
obstruction of justice the goalposts
moving is it used to be obstruction of
justice no way nohow
put it out of your mind and now the
conversation has shifted to even if the
president obstructed justice the
president can't actually be charged with
that because they are President of the
United States that's a new conversation
where the goal posts have been moved so
far that they're in the locker room or
the parking lot of the stadium arguing
that you couldn't possibly be charged
with obstruction of justice is not a
strong position it's a weak position now
to the first part could a president be
charged with obstruction differing
opinions about this when you look at the
articles of impeachment filed against
Richard Nixon they started by saying
that Nixon obstructed and impeded the
administration of justice Bob Woodward
believes that this is not really a
settled issue but said that
realistically the only actual path
forward for Trump's removal would be
impeachment or resignation and that you
certainly shouldn't be counting on
getting the President on criminal
obstruction of justice charges but
remember Bill Clinton was impeached for
perjury and obstruction of justice and
what are we coming to we're coming to
endless and far-reaching investigations
of everyone at every level here because
it's not just Trump we learned about
katie mcfarland we learned about jeff
sessions we learned about Mike Flynn and
Jared Kushner in pence the Republican
Party held years of hearings over
Benghazi for Hillary Clinton they
impeached Bill Clinton for lying about
oral sex they flipped out when Obama
wore a tan suit and they just want this
to go away so what we need to do is to
continue talking about everything else
that's going on in politics net
neutrality tax cuts health care
everything but we can't let this go
way.this is growing to be one of the
biggest scandals in the history of
american presidencies already four
indictments three investigations in a
revolving door of personal lawyers for
donald trump trying to keep him out of
harm's way
we cannot let it go away and
interestingly we also need to call out
the insane flip-flops and hypocrisy from
Republicans on this issue of whether a
president can obstruct justice and
that's why I want to talk to you about
Jeff Sessions next